un excellent résultat et qui mérite
d'être souligné dans sa
composition la première c'est que nous
doublons le nombre de députés en
Bourgogne nous doublons et que parmi ces
députés aujourd'hui 10 députés de
Bourgogne passant de 5 à 10 il y a 4
femmes d'élu les qure sont membres du
Parti socialiste avouez quand même que
presque arriv à la parité en Bourgogne
dans un contexte politique qui difficile
pour la gauche dans les deux
départements du Nord entre Lyonne et la
Côte d'Or carton plein dans la Nive
carton plein on se néloire on revient à
une configuration d'il y a une vingtaine
d'années je pense que pour la Bourgogne
c'est c'est un bon résultat pour le
national j'imagine aujourd'hui que de
pouvoir avoir obtenu la majorité absolue
c'est c'est une grande victoire c'est un
score que le Parti socialiste n'avait
pas connu depuis 30 ans et moi je pense
comme d'habitude que les soires de
d'élection il faut à la fois savourer
ses victoires et assumer ses défaites
mais ce soir entre les deux sentiments
qui me partagent je n'hésite pas bien
entendu la joie de la victoire ce soir
de la gauche de la majorité
présidentielle et de ses alliés mais
aussi la responsabilité et la gravité
face